tomorrow is a major deadline for dieter
to restart payments for certain
claimants
the court order forcing it to do that
came after dieter was actually
found in contempt our joe mohler is live
with an update on this deadline joe
this is all coming from the pua dieter
case that court order was issued for
dieter to pay
to resume payments for certain claimants
now this is sends back from the summer
uh dieter was supposed to resume
payments for those who had payments
stopped for one reason or another
there is an estimated nine thousand of
those claimants now attorney mark
thurman who represents poor claimants
expects there is much more than that the
original court order was issued in the
summer and when
it wasn't met the court found the
department in content
the deadline to resume those payments is
tomorrow per the new order i spoke to
thurman today about
what he is noticing
many people have gotten a change on
their website portal that says
that due to the court uh order their the
uh
deduction or the stock payment has been
reversed
but as far as we know no one has
actually gotten a check or a payment
some of them have
payment numbers or transaction numbers
but no corresponding money in their
account
now the next hearing on this is set for
next week on the 31st theorem and
expects the department to put a
statement into the court updating how
many cases of fraud they have identified
before then